]
♪ ♪
>> HERE WE ARE ONCE AGAIN.
HAPPY TUESDAY EVERY BODY, YES,
IT IS TUESDAY.
I LOVE TUESDAY TWO.
NOW, THIS IS TYPICALLY THE TIME
OF THE YEAR, WHERE THERE'S NOT
MUCH NEWS TO TALK ABOUT.
UNLESS SOMEBODY DECIDES TO BURN
DOWN OUR CHRISTMAS TREE AGAIN.
BUT I THINK CHRIS WALLACE IS OUT
OF TOWN THIS YEAR.
[LAUGHTER]
GMAC JAMIE BLAMES IT ON THE
HOMELESS GUY, BUT FRANKLY, LOTS
OF PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THE NEWS
ARE NOT WORKING.
HONESTLY, DANA HAS BEEN FOLK
PHONING IT IN FOR WEEKS.
ASA SHANNON HAS BEEN TOO BUSY
STEALING KIDS TOYS.
SHE IS EVIL.
BUT IT'S WEIRD, YOU NOTICE A
TREND WHEN ALL THE NEWS PEOPLE
ARE AWAY, AWAY GOES THE NEWS AS
WELL.
AND WHAT IS BEING CALLED THIS
RIGHT NOW, AS EVEN CRAFTER THAN
USUAL.
LIKE THE JAN STICKS COMMITTEE
SHOW TRIAL.
THEY WOULD LITERALLY, PART OF
THE ABC PRODUCER TO SLAP THAT
DIARRHEA.
[LAUGHTER]
I DO LIKE THAT IMAGE.
THIS WEEK THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE VOTED THAT THEY
SHOULD -- HERE'S A FORMER
PRESIDENT WHEN HE HAD THE NEWS
ABOUT JANUARY 6.
[LAUGHTER]
>> SERVICES FOR THE NEWS?
NO, STILL BE SURPRISING THANK
SINCE I WAS VOTED TO BE THE
COVER OF SNC'S 2022 HOW.
TAKE THAT HAMMER.
THERE IS A NEW SHERIFF IN TOWN,
HIS CHAPS ARE MADE OF LEATHER.
THEY HEAR BOTH THE MEDIA AND THE
WHITE HOUSE AGREED, JANUARY 6TH
WAS THE WORST THING SINCE THE
CIVIL WAR.
BUT I BET LINK ENGLISH IS THE
WORST THING THAT HAPPENED TO HIM
WAS THAT SOMEBODY JUST STOLE HIS
PODIUM.
BECAUSE HE WAS SHOT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THE AUDIENCE, JANUARY 6TH WAS
JUST LIKE THE CIVIL WAR TO AOC,
BECAUSE SHE WASN'T AND THAT
EITHER.
ANYWAY, THE FAKE PANEL
RECOMMENDED THAT THEY CHARGED
TRUMP WITH INSURRECTION,
ABSTRACTION WITH OFFICIAL
PROCEEDING, MAKING FALSE
STATEMENTS, AND CONSPIRACY TO
DEFRAUD THE U.S. GOVERNMENT.
THEY LEFT AT THE JFK
ASSASSINATION.
BUT ALL OF THIS IS B.S. ON HIS
FACE.
WHICH I HEAR KEEPS PELOSI'S KEEP
LOOKING YOUNG.
JUST RUBBING IT IN.
IF HE CAN HANDLE THE SMELL.
BUT THIS WHOLE THOUGH, IT IS THE
LEAST SHOCKING THING IN POLITICS
SINCE EPSTEIN WAS FOUND DEAD IN
HIS CELL INHALER IT WAS SEEN
LEAVING THE SCENE ON A BROOM.
THE MOST SHOCKING THING IN
POLITICS, AS WHEN BILLY SANDERS
ACTED IN REPEAT ON ELECTRIC
CATTLE FENCE.
NOT AS FUN AS IT LOOKS.
OF COURSE, THE COMMITTEE WAS
MOST LOPSIDED MOB SINCE THE
VILLAGERS WENT AFTER
FRANKENSTEIN.
AND THEY MADE IT ONE-SIDED FOR A
REASON.
THAT'S HOW THE THIRD HAND
ACCOUNT OF TRUMP ATTACKING
SECRET SERVICE FROM THE BACK
STREET OF SUV SUDDENLY BECOME
EVIDENCE.
THE ONLY TWO REPUBLICANS ON THE
PANEL, WAS LIZ, AND ADAMS.
THE CONDOS TO REPUBLICANS IS
LIKE COMING THE WNBA
PROFESSIONAL BASKETBALL.
>> AS A SUCCESS WOULD SAY.
IT IS DISGUSTING.
HERE'S LIZ AND ADAM, TALKING
ABOUT TRUMP.
>> WOW, THE WHOLE THING WAS A
SPOIL AND AS THEY ARE, NOT ONLY
A REPUBLICAN SIX AFFECTED TO
DISSOLVE THIS COMMITTEE WHEN
THEY COULD CONTROL THE HOUSE,
THOSE TWO WET WINDBAGS, THEY ARE
ON THEIR WAY OUT.
THEY WILL BE SWITCHING PARTIES
THAT MY NEW YEAR'S GUESTS WHO
WHEN KILL ME SHOWS UP.
DANNY LOST HER PRIMARY TO JERRY
HITTING HIM AND WOULD BUY 37
POINTS, AND I HAVE NOTHING OF
LOT LIKE THAT SINCE NIXON GOT
HIS THINGS DONE.
AND HE'S RETIRING, PERHAPS TO
AUDITION FOR A MORE FEMININE
VOICE ON THE VIEW.
AND THEY BOTH WANT TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT.
AND I SAY WE MADE THE BEST GIRL
WAITING.
I AM KIDDING OF COURSE, BUT THEY
ARE JERKS BECAUSE THEY ARE
DISGUSTED BY HALF THE COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW THE GOOD HALF.
AND THEY'RE WILLING TO SOLVE THE
RUINS OF VOTERS, BECAUSE
DONALD TRUMP WASN'T THEIR
BEST FRIEND, SO THE LEAVE THE
COUNTRY BY PUSHING JAIL FOR
TRUMP.
MEANWHILE, YOU ALSO HAVE THE
WHITE HOUSE ECHOING THE
SENTIMENTS.
>> WHAT WE SAW ON JANUARY 6TH
WAS THE WORST ATTACK IN OUR
DEMOCRACY SINCE THE CIVIL WAR,
IN OUR DEMOCRACY STILL CONTINUES
TO REMAIN UNDER THREAT.
>> WHAT DOES IT SAY WHEN TO
REPUBLICANS SOUND LIKE
COURAGEOUS JOHN PAUL.
OH IT WORKS.
CRINGE.
>> I MADE HE IS RIGHT, YOU DO
CRINGE JOHN PAUL.
>> THIS IS IN A STICK.
OKAY FINE LET ME FINISH
COMMITTEE.
BUT IT DOES MADE ME LONG FOR THE
HONESTY OF JEN PSAKI.
JANUARY 6TH, IS THAT TERRY
THERAPY.
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING,
DOESN'T OBLIGATE FEDS TO BRING
IN A CASE, THE HEARING WAS A
POLITICAL VENDETTA DISGUISED AS
A HEARING BUT TURN INTO A TRIAL.
BUT THIS ISN'T ANY MORE
SURPRISING THAN OUR PRESIDENT
HAD PRESIDENT HUFFING A BOTTLE
OF JOHNSON & JOHNSON AND NUMBER
TEARS SHAMPOO.
JUST A PIECE OF FAKE NEWS IN A
WEEK, WITH A NETWORKS TAKE WHAT
THEY CAN GET.
AND THEY TOOK UP BECAUSE THEY
ARE RIDING ON VACATIONS FOR
REALITY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> LET US WALK ON TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
THIS KENNEDY NEVER TAKES A
BACKSEAT.
IT'S A KID AND HE AND, KENNEDY.
HE DRESSES UP AS SANTA, BECAUSE
IT IS THE ONLY WAY HE GETS TO
SEE HIS KIDS.
ACTOR, WRITER, AND COMEDIAN
JAMIE RIVERS OUT.
SHE IS I CAN ICICLE, COLD,
SHARP, I CAN BE FOUND HANGING
UPSIDE DOWN YOUR DOORWAY,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR...
-- AND, A WINTER SOLSTICE
STARTS WHEN HE OPENS HIS FRIDGE,
MY MASSIVE PSYCHIC AND THE NW
HEAVYWEIGHT CHAMPION TYRUS.
KENNEDY, I WANT TO GO TO YOUR
FIRST BECAUSE LIKE ME YOU'VE
BEEN IN THIS BUSINESS A LONG
TIME USING THE UPS, DOWNS, THE
SIDEWAYS.
>> INDIANS AND THE OUTS.
>> MEANS IN THE HOUSE YES, DID
YOU NOTICE THE CORRELATION
BETWEEN A SLOW NEWS DAY, AND AN
ABSENCE OF NEWS PEOPLE BECAUSE
WHENEVER THERE, SUDDENLY THE
KILLING STOPS IS EVERYTHING JUST
STOP?
AND I WOULD JUST TALK ABOUT
WHETHER?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
YES, IF THERE ARE NO NEWSPEOPLE
IN THE FOREST, DO THE TREES THAT
MAKE ANY SOUND?
WHEN THE BRANCHES SNAP UP?
DOES NOT MEAN THAT THERE IS JUST
MANUFACTURING NEWS?
BY AND LARGE, THE ANSWER IS YES
AND ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS LOOK
AT THE NEWS THAT THEY HAVE
IGNORED.
AND LOOK AT THE NEWS THAT THEY
ARE FOCUSED ON.
AND YOU REALIZE THAT THERE IS A
GREAT IMBALANCE IN THIS COUNTRY
IN TERMS OF PEOPLE SPEAKING
TRUTH TO POWER.
ALL THEY ARE DOING, IS BOTHERING
US OUR THEY DON'T AGREE WITH.
BUT AGREEING WITH SOMETHING,
DOESN'T MAKE IT TRUE, DOESN'T
MAKE IT RIGHT, BUT WE HAVE GIVEN
UP ON OBJECTIVE JOURNALISM IN
THE COUNTRY.
AND I THINK MOST PEOPLE WHO CALL
THEMSELVES JOURNALISTS, SHOULD
JUST GIVE UP, AND START SELLING
HOUSES.
>> YES.
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY THE PEOPLE
WORKING ON THE TWITTER FILES,
ARE GREAT.
>> AND VERY WHITE.
>> AND V THING, BUT YOU'RE
LAUGHING BECAUSE A TERRIBLE
MANY.
BUT I THOUGHT NOT HAD MUCH
SLEEP, YOU KNOW I CAN A PUPPY
AND I HAVE NOT SLEPT.
YOU KNOW JAMIE, WAS WONDERING AS
I WAS GETTING HERE WHOSE HATRED
WAS WORSE, LISTEN ADAM TOWARDS
TRUMP, FOR YOUR EX-WIFE.
YOU?
>> THE LATTER.
>> THAT SHE TAKE THE LATTER TWO?
>> YES.
BECAUSE SHE TOOK THE HOUSE.
>> NO I GET IT.
I'M LIKE A BITTER BATTLE OF
SULTAN MOON.
[LAUGHTER]
DO YOU HAVE ANY LEMON SLICES.
>> ACTUALLY NEEDED THE LATTER
EXPLANATION TO GET IT.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF I'M JUST
STUPID.
>> THAT MAKES LATTER-DAY SAINTS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> NO YOUR COURAGE AND GO AHEAD
KEEP GOING.
THE MIKE I DO HAVE A PROBLEM
IT'S OKAY.
NOW THEY CAN RELEASE HIS TAX
FILES, IT'S LIKE SAYING WHAT
KENNEDY SAID THEY'RE PUTTING
REAL NEWS, AND OTHER THAN A
RELEASE HIS TAX RETURNS HAVEN'T
HAD ENOUGH?
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE?
>> I'M STILL REELING ABOUT THIS
NEWS ABOUT LINCOLN.
I HAD NO IDEA, THAT'S THE
GREATEST THING ABOUT KNOWING
NOTHING ABOUT LINK HISTORY.
WATCHING MOVIES AND BEING
SURPRISED.
I WAS WATCHING PEARL HARBOR AND
I WAS WATCHING WHAT THEY DID.
BUT IT CANNOT CHANGE YOUR VIEW.
>> THE WHOLE THING, HAD IT ALL
WRONG.
BUT, WHAT IRRITATES ME TO MOSES
THE PRESS SECRETARY COMPARING
JANUARY 6 TO THE CIVIL WAR.
THAT IS INSANE.
ALSO PEOPLE SAYING THAT IT'S
COMPARING APPLES TO ORANGES.
I FEEL LIKE THAT IS NOT A
HORRIBLE COMPARISON.
I THINK WE SHOULD GET RID OF THE
WHOLE SAYING OF APPLES TO
ORANGES BECAUSE THEY'RE BOTH
CIRCLE, AND BOTH FRUIT.
AND WE SHOULD CHANGE IT TO SAY
THAT BY COMPARING THE PRESS
SECRETARY TO SOMEBODY WHO'S NOT
A IDIOT.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT IS IN IT.
ISN'T IT INSULTING THOUGH, I
FEEL LIKE IT IS ALMOST INSULTING
ALMOST.
I IMAGINE TALKING TO SOMEBODY
AND SAY WERE BOTH IN THE
SERVICE, AND SAYING YEAH I WAS
IN AFGHANISTAN, THE END SOMEONE
ELSE SAID THAT THEY WERE THERE
IN JANUARY 6.
I MEAN HOW LONG WILL YOU AND
THEREFORE?
HALF A DAY.
I GOT HOME BEFORE
"WHEEL OF FORTUNE."
[LAUGHTER]
>> A COUPLE OF FALLEN BROTHERS
WHAT THEY GOT BACK UP.
>> IT'S EMBARRASSING TO ME.
>> IT IS, I WOULD NOT COMPARE
JANUARY 6 TO CIVIL WAR, BUT I
WILL COMPARE IT TO JAN BRADY.
CIVIL WAR.
WITH THE BRADY BUNCH IN MIDAIR.
I KNOW HOW YOU FEEL, YOU LOOK AT
THIS AND SAY THERE GOES, OUR TAX
DOLLARS AGAIN.
>> I JUST DO NOT UNDERSTAND JUST
BECAUSE SOMETHING HAPPENED AFTER
A VERY BAD THING, AS IN THE
YOUTH AND COMPARE TO TWO THINGS.
IF YOU CAN FIND SOME LITTLE
THING IN COMMON LIKE -- EIGHT
YEARS AGO MY MOTHER DIED.
OKAY, AT SOME POINT AFTER THAT,
MY DAD TOOK A NAP.
[LAUGHTER]
TECHNICALLY YOU COULD SAY THAT
THAT WAS THE WORSE INSTANCE OF
TRYING TO REACH A PARENT.
I MAY SINCE MY MOTHER'S UNTIMELY
DEATH.
BUT I WOULD NEVER MAKE THAT A
COMPARISON BECAUSE IT IS INSANE.
SO I HAD NO IDEA HOW YOU CAN GET
AWAY WITH SAYING SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
BUT I THINK SHE JUST SAYS
SOMETHING LIKE THAT ALL THE TIME
SO WERE GETTING USED TO IT.
>> YES, IT IS THEIR SHOW TYRUS,
PHIL WAS AS BAD AS THE
CIVIL WAR?
>> SURE.
REMEMBER, MINISTER TO JANUARY 6
I GOT A TEXT SAYING YOU'RE NOT
FREE ANYMORE.
REPORT TO GEORGIA THE COTTON
LINE.
THEN IT STOPPED AND I WAS LIKE
ALL THOSE IS ALMOST AS BAD AS
THE CIVIL WAR I THINK.
>> YOU KNOW HERE'S THE THING.
IF THIS IS WHAT IMPEACHMENT
NUMBER THREE, THIS WAS IS WHAT
IT WAS, VERDURE SIGNALLY.
THERE'S A LOT TO GET CANCER.
IT'S COMING, THEY HAD TO GET IT
OUT.
BUT AGAIN, WHEN THIS FIRST COME
OUT, THERE WERE THESE TWO
AGENCIES AND ANOTHER NOT POPULAR
WITH US RIGHT NOW, BUT THE CIA
AND FBI, THEY DID A PRETTY GOOD
INVESTIGATION TO DETERMINE THAT
THE PRESIDENT WAS NOT THE
CHARACTER THAT THEY WERE
INVESTIGATING.
OKAY, MAYBE HE WAS A JERK ABOUT
IT.
BUT IT CLEARLY WASN'T PLANNING
AND ET CETERA.
THAT MEANS, NOTHING TO THEM.
BECAUSE THEY NEEDED ONE MORE
THING, BECAUSE THEY'RE TRYING TO
STOP HIM FROM GETTING REELECTED.
SO THIS IS HOW THEY TRY TO DO
IT.
>> BUT AGAIN, IF SOMETHING IS
TRULY BAD.
IF I LOST BOTH MY LEGS AND A
SHARK ATTACK, I DON'T HAVE TO
COMPARE IT TO ANYTHING ELSE.
I LOST MY LEGS IN A SHARK
ATTACK.
SHOWS JANUARY 6 WAS THAT BAD,
YOU DO NOT NEED TO COMPARE TO
ANYTHING.
>> IT THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> WHY WOULD YOU COMPARE IT.
>> YOU DON'T NEED TO COMPARE IT.
>> BECAUSE I REMEMBER WHEN 9/11
HAPPENED, WE WERE DOING
COMPARISON.
>> 9/11 WAS THE TIME I MISS THE
BOAT IS A MISS SCHOOL.
NO.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT SIMILAR TO,
GORDON LIDDY ALWAYS HATED WHEN
THEY WOULD TAG GATE ONTO THE
LAND OF SCANDAL.
THEY TRAVEL.
ENTERING GATE, THAT WAS THE NAME
OF THE HOTEL IN THE OFFICE
BUILDING WITH APRIL GAME.
HE DOESN'T SIGNAL ANYTHING ELSE
BUT THE ONE THING THEY HAVE
STOPPED COMPARING EVERYTHING TO
HIS HITLER.
SO THAT IS THEIR SLIGHTLY MORE
SOPHISTICATED THEN.
>> I REMEMBER WHEN THAT GUY
STOLE MY GATE AND WE ARE TELLING
GATE GAME.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT THEN I HAD A LIMP.
AND THAT WAS >>